los aeropuertos Entonces ya están
cerrados qué otras medidas pueden tomar
las autoridades para tratar de minimizar
el impacto de este huracán
Saludos Daniel allá a todos los puertos
marítimos de puertos aéreos ha sido
cerrados como bien mencionas es parte de
la cuando se emite un aviso de tormenta
tropical pero hace unas horas se
estableció ya que es un huracán
categoría 1 tiene viento sostenido de 80
millas por hora y yo estoy en el área
donde más fuerte se va a sentir porque
estoy en el sur de Puerto Rico Así que
el llamado a la ciudadanía en este
momento definitivamente es a mantenerse
en sus hogares el llamado previo era
desalojar áreas inundables y en este
momento Pues estamos recibiendo
directamente el impacto de un huracán
categoría 1
señor Crespo que tan preparado esta
Puerto Rico para afrontar un huracán de
grandes magnitudes teniendo en cuenta
que todavía quedan secuelas del desastre
que trajo consigo el huracán María hace
cinco años y considerado en ese momento
el más letal de la historia de Puerto
Rico la electricidad por ejemplo no ha
vuelto a la normalidad
el sistema eléctrico de Puerto Rico es
una de las cosas más lastimadas que
tiene nuestra infraestructura no solo
por su longevidad se como bien has dicho
por el impacto del huracán María se ha
asignado una un presupuesto grandísimo
históricamente nunca Estados Unidos
había llevado a cabo un desembolso como
ese para la reparación de lo que
conocemos acá como el grit eléctrico sin
embargo Pues todavía todo esos
desembolsos toma mucha planificación
siempre hay temas burocráticos Así que
es uno de los temas más importantes
Unidos a la erosión costera que
precisamente se exacerbó no solamente
por el calentamiento global y el aumento
en el nivel del mar sino por la marejada
ciclónica de María Así que hay muchas
comunidades vulnerables y uno de los
riesgos mayores precisamente son ese
tipo de comunidades que están en zonas
inundables ahora mismo bueno y Qué
implicaciones tiene Entonces esta
declaración de Estados Unidos de
emergencia en la zona que en que cambia
eso la situación
es un alivio precisamente para los
gobiernos municipales en Puerto Rico el
nivel de gobierno más básico es el
gobierno municipal y los alcaldes y
alcaldes son los respondedores de
emergencia así que por lo menos ellos
van a poder hacer una reclamación de los
gastos previos al incidente los gastos
en la categoría de respuestas un
programa que se conoce como el programa
de asistencia pública las categorías a y
b cuando se aprueba o se declara estado
de emergencia van a ser elegibles para
reembolso de ese tipo de gastos